وراء كل خبر قصه تروى تدقيق ورصد بالصوره
شاشه يمتد عمرها لاكثر من عشرين عاما ان
تعرف اكثر مهمه العربيه من عام لاخر الان
جاء دور الصوت والكلمه من العاصمه
السعوديه الرياض ولدت اذاعه العربيه
العربيه اف ام تضعك في الصوره لتعرف
اكثر ومن قلب استديوهات الاخبار بالرياض
بضاعه العربيه تكمل الصوره خبرا لكل
المستمعين فصلكم حيثما كنتم اسرع من اي
وقت اتمنى ان يصلكم الخبر فور حدوثه
واينما كنتم بالصوت والكلمه سنقدم لك كل
ما يهمك ان تعرفه عبر صباح العربيه اف ام
لطالما كانت الفكره وتفرد المحتوى هما حجر
الزاويه منذ نشاه العربيه تواصل الاذاعه
المشوار بخطى ثابته في بث يمتد عبر الاثير
والوسائط المتعدده الى مستمعيها في العالم
اجمع
عصام عبد السلام اذاعه العربيه اف ام